please
[Applause]
desperation
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Mike miles Jr
what an incredible performance sure in
this situation
Coast goes up finish it with the nice
floater over the shot blocker Warren
Washington
but it was Mike miles Jr to lead TCU
hauling frogs to this victory
what I loved about this play Avery was
Mike miles Jr gave it up he trusts his
teammate Jacoby Cole 6-7 against the
smaller Collins plump fake and the
presence of mind to be able to drive the
basketball and shoot an Exploder that's
a tough shot for me he made it look easy
handicap standing by with the winners
I got some Happy Frogs right here Mike
miles Jacoby calls uh let me stretch
over here for a minute here at the
Jacobi uh take me through that last
possession how you converted the
game-winning bucket uh well I know that
was probably going double Mike and that
was the second option my shots a lot was
really flat today and I knew I was
trying to get that last one a little bit
in the air and thank God I got it from
you you knew they were gonna double you
so what did you see when the double came
uh you know I kind of learned from last
year you know I ain't want to you know
do the same thing so I got out the ball
so Kobe was open he made the right play
we won the game how are you still
standing here you were beaten down yeah
the monster dunk we didn't know if
you're gonna play in the second half how
are you here I started out trying to
Matt man he got me right you know God
doesn't lock Aroma has time to calm down
you know get back out here and I was
gonna go back regards I want to help my
team it's a big tournament I'm a big
time player so that's what it's about
you certainly are Jacoby how about the
resiliency of these frogs man we've been
fighting all year even without their
injuries a lot of adversity but we're
all Brothers man we're all happy
together and we came out here and stuck
together and got this win got support
for us and we ready to go to the next
round all right on the Sunday of the
zags
great stuff yeah let's go let's go I
love the emotion from the field tonight
it's Collins taking it out two horn gets
the touch shot talks not in play
clutch
locked at 70.
[Applause]
let's watch this that's individual play
DJ horn knocks this down look at his
shooting percentage tonight he's five
for nine from the field four or five
from the three-point line they've missed
him a few times especially in that first
half he's had a hot hand for the Sun
Devils
and Walker cut him off he initially was
trying to drive and get to his right
hand he got cut off and